[Music]
Winterfell if we do not defeat the night
king it is not just the end of us it's
the end of all of mankind we must defend
our home against the White Walkers we
must fight
[Music]
ladies why are you coming
look job we not battered okay we know
you invited all the Seven Kingdoms here
to fight the war against the White
Walkers that's why we came up from the
Summer Isles what it's too cold John
plus we're heading back home for a
[Applause]
people we see so far but we're holding
out hope the Sun would like a cup this
is the year I don't understand do you
want to fight or do you want to die Oh
honestly I don't want to do either don't
sound real bad
it's freezing John this is not the
weather of my ancestors mmm-hmm besides
I'm not gonna miss the annual black only
key needed to fight a white man it's not
the white man's war this is all of our
war your privilege is show and John and
it ain't cute
what do you mean my privilege look
around we are literally the only black
people here I'm sorry isn't our top
unsullied gray one a black oh my man
would know dick y'all just had to in the
brown man workhorse
okay Khaleesi is right hand miss sandy
surely she must share your heritage Oh
me I have not seen her hair's never
[Music]
thinking reaching the Dothraki Khal
Drogo wasn't he served bike what is
sorta black so black like that yes yes
Khal Drogo might be dead but I put a
road that's down a battle not nonsense
we need everyone fighting winter is here
oh bitch
[Music]
Sunkist people I'm here to save you not
me we all need a way fine
Sunkist people you stay John mm-hmm come
with me we'll get on my dragon okay
Johnny
worse than the Mad King oh my god you
guys might all froze
Wow
[Laughter]
you milking it now
oh wait we could be the first
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you